[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالصراخ والتوتر وتبادل الاتهامات انتهى
اجتماع المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
السياسيه والامنيه الاسرائيلي مساء الخميس
ما يعكس حاله انعدام الثقه بين مكونات
المستويين السياسي والعسكري على خلفيه
الحرب في غزه فاجتماع الذي خلاله وزراء
بالمجلس المصغر هجوما شرسا على رئيس هيئه
الاركان بسبب اختياراته لاعضاء فريق
التحقيق في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر انتهى
وفق الاذاعه الاسرائيليه بانسحاب مسؤولين
عسكريين منه عضو مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
بني جانس انتقد بشده الهجوم على رئيس
الاركان في مجلس الوزراء قائلا ان دوافعه
سياسيه ملمحا الى ان ما د في الاجتماع كشف
تغليب نتنياهو مصالحه الشخصيه السياسيه
على امن اسرائيل اما زعيم المعارضه اير
لابيد فقد وصف بداره في هذا الاجتماع بانه
وصمه عار ودليل اخر على خطوره هذه الحكومه
التي يراسها نتنياهو والتي عاد ليصف لاحقا
بانها كارثه وطنيه مطالبا بتبديلها
والتخلص من رئيسها لانها غير قادره على
اتخاذ قرار استراتيجي وفق تعبيره خلاف اخر
لا يقل خطوره نشب بين نهو ووزير دفاعه
يواف جلان سببه منع نتنياهو رئيسي المساد
والشباك من حضور جلسه لحكومه الحرب وهو ما
وصفه وزير الدفاع بانه مضر بامن البلاد
وفق تعبيره الخلافات الاخذه في الازدياد
على مستويين القياده السياسيه والعسكريه
في اسرائيل تتزامن مع تقديرات لوزاره
الدفاع كشفتها صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت عن ان
عدد الجنود المصابين با اعاقات في الحرب
قد يصل الى
12500 خبر قد يزيد حاله انعدام الثقه في
الحكومه التي تتزايد يوما بعد يوم ضغوط
دوي المحتجزين في غزه من اجل دفعها لصفقه
تبادل الاسر تعيد اليهم
[موسيقى]
ابنائهم نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من
بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من الخليل عادل شديد الباحث
المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي ومن غزه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي حسام الدجني نبدا
من الخليل والسيد عادل شديد ما مدى خطوره
خروج هذه الخلافات الى
العلن مساء الخير لك استاذ محمد ولضيوفك
وللمشاهدة
12500 عدد
الذين سينضم الى هذا الجيش الكبير من
المعاقين في سنه 23 24 والذي يشكل 20% من
مجموع اولئك المعاقين العسكريين منذ اقامه
اسرائيل حتى اليوم هذا الرقم هو حد الادنى
تقرير بدعو حرت قل من 12500 وقد يصل الى
20,000 بمعنى الحد الادنى
12500 اما بخصوص ال
موضوع الواقع الحالي ما بين مكونات واطياف
النظام السياسي في اسرائيل سواء السياسي
والامني والعسكري واضح تماما انه اليوم
ليس فقط مساله يعني ثقه شخصيه اليوم
انهارت الثقه الشخصيه حتى داخل يعني ممثلي
حزب الليكود بالحكومه بمعنى انه لم تعد
الازمه ما بين جنتس من جهه او رئيس
الاركان مع رئيس الحكومه انما ما بين
بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير
الجيش جالنت الذي ينتمي الى حزب اللكود
والاخطر من ذلك انه اليوم انهيار الثقه
اخذ ليس فقط ابعادا شخصيه او ابعادا حزبيه
انما ابعاد مؤسسيه هنالك شبه انعدام ثقه
ما بين المستوى السياسي ممثل بالحكومه
وشركاء بنيامين نتنياهو وتحديدا صهيونيه
الدينيه جماعه سموتريش و وشركاءه و جماعه
بن كفير القاعده اليمينيه المتشدده في حزب
الكود من جهه وما بين الجيش كمؤسسه والذي
تحرص اسرائيل منذ اقامه الدوله ان لا يمثل
جيش وان يبقى بعيدا وخارج كل التجاذبات
السياسيه حتى انه وصف بالسبعينات
والثمانينات بالبقره المقدسه انه ممنوع
الاقتراب من انتقاد الجيش يجب ان يبقى
الجيش فوق كل التناقضات منذ بدايه الحرب
الحاليه المقربين من نتنياهو وهذا اصبح
واضح لكل النخبه العسكريه في اسرائيل سواء
النخبه العسكريه الحاليه التي تردد الزي
العسكري وعلى راس الخدمه او اولئك
المتقاعدين باتوا مقتنعين ان بنيمين
نتنياهو يقوم بحمله تحريض واسعه ضد الجيش
وضد الامن ويحملهم مسؤوليه الفشل الكبير
بالسابع من اكتوبر وما تلى السابع من
اكتوبر
وليسق المهمه التي تتحدث عنها سيد شديد
بعد اذنك نسال عنها العميد الياس
حنا خطوره الخلاف بين المستوى السياسي
والمستوى العسكري عندما تكون اي دوله في
زمن
حرب
ا
محمد المهم اليوم ان كل شيء على البعد
العسكري ينطلق من البعد السياسي يعني حصلت
اي ايه طوفان الاقصى 7 اكتوبر هذا اسقط
منظومه امنيه كبيره جدا وحتى قناعات امنيه
استخباراتيه
واستراتيجيه هذا الامر غطته الحرب على غزه
اليوم نتائج ما يجري على ارض غزه عكس او
المستوى التكتيكي عكس على المستوى
الاستراتيجي هذه الخلافات يعني اليوم
عندما وضعت الحكومه السياسيه الاهداف
الكبرى وهي كما يقال ماكسيمال يعني اهداف
القصوى يعني تدمير حماس تدمير البنى
التحتيه وانشاء بيئه في قطاع غزه ما بعد
حماس وليس لحماس وجود فيها اليوم هذه هي
الاهداف السياسيه عندما بدات المعركه منذ
فتره تقريبا ثلاثه اشهر عكست ارض الميدان
عكست الوضع التكتيكي والعملانية
بدا الجيش يتاقلم والدليل على ذلك انسحاب
وتحرير خمسه الويه من الاحتياط ولكن البعد
السياسي لم يتحرك يعني لم
يعدل المهم دائما هو هذه الاستراتيجيه هي
كائن حي يتغير بين البعد السياسي والبعد
العسكري يجب ان يكون هناك تواصل نتنياهو
مصر على التدمير الكامل وبالتالي لا شيء
في غزه ل لحماس علاقه فيه ولكن الواقع
العسكري يعكس فكره مختلفه تماما من هنا
هذه التعديلات وصلنا الى مرحلات الانقسام
السياسي والانقسام السياسي الحاد والعلني
وهنا تكمل الخطوره على الاداء العسكري نعم
مثل ما اشرت يعني ربما بالنسبه للمقاومه
سيد حسام الدجني هل هذه الخلافات تهمها من
قريب او من بعيد بالنسبه لسير ما يجري في
غزه
بالتاكيد المقاومه ترصد كل كبيره وصغيره
في داخل اسرائيل بل على العكس هي فاعل
اساسي ورئيسي في تعزيز هذا الخلاف وهو احد
اوجه الانتصار الذي ممكن ان تحققه
المقاومه من خلال اللعب على هذا الوطر
وتعزيز تيار على تيار وبذلك
عندما نلاحظ مثلا المواد الاعلاميه التي
تضخها المقاومه فيما يتعلق بالاسرى هي
موجهه
لتعزيز فكره ان يكون هنا ك حراك مجتمعي في
داخل اسرائيل ضد بنيامين نتنياهو تستغل
المعارضه حتى رساله السيد اسماعيل هانيه
الى بلينكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي هي من
باب تعزيز ايضا الموقف الامريكي الذي ترى
المقاومه ان جانس هو مرتبط بشكل اكثر مع
الاداره الامريكيه ولا يمكن ان يخالف هذه
التوجهات وبذلك تعزز من فكره تفسق
الائتلاف الحاكم في هذا في هذه الحرب الذي
يدير هذا الكيان ويدير هذه الحرب وبذلك كل
صغيره وكل كبيره في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي حتى المؤشر الاقتصادي المقاومه
تتابعه موضوع التسريبات الاعلاميه في
تقديري انها ترصدها بشكل جيد وتحاول ان
تعزز من خلال مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وتخصيص مواد باللغه العبريه لكي تصل الى
المجتمع الاسرائيلي في ظل الرقد العسكري
لذلك المقاومه ليست بعيده عن الفواعل في
داخل اسرائيل وهذا اوباما الذي يطرح تساؤل
ان اسرائيل دائما تطرح سؤال ماذا بعد غزه
وكانها حسمت المعركه وكانها انتصرت في هذه
المعركه بينما في الواقع ان المقاومه على
الارض تزداد قوه وبالمناسبه هي كمان تؤثر
وتحدد ماذا بعد نتنياهو وماذا بعد يعني
الخيارات في داخل اسرائيل وبذلك نعم
المقاومه فاعل مهم في هذه اللعبه هل هل من
تفسير سيد عادل شديد لماذا غلاه اليمين في
حكومه نتنياهو هم الاشرس في انتقاد
المؤسسه
العسكريه لسبب بسيط انه مشروع اليمين لا
يمكن ان يقبل من قبل المستوى العسكري
مشروع اليمين واضح يراد استغلال ما يحدث
الان لاعاده ما اسموه معالجه اخطاء شارون
واتفاقيه اوسلو والمتمثل باعاده بناء
الاستيطان في قطاع غزه وتهجير الشعب
الفلسطيني من هناك وتموضع عسكري دائم
اعاده الاحتلال الدائم وهذا يعني توريط
اسرائيل والى الابد
الجهه اليمينيه يمين الخارطه في اسرائيل
سموتر شوبن كفير يعون تماما ان هنالك
موقفا منسجما ما بين الولايات المتحده
والنخبه العسكريه يرفض ذلك جمله وتفصيلا
لما له من تداعيات ثم انه الخطاب اليمين
الاسرائيلي يتبنى الحد الاقصى من استخدام
القوه يعني رغم الاباده الجماعيه رغم
22000 شهيد و6000 مصاب هذا من وجهه نظر
اليمين غير كافي بالتالي يريد يردون اعطاء
الجيش ما يسمى بالحد الاقصى من الصلاحيه
وكان الجيش تم تكبيل يديه وبالمناسبه اول
حرب بتاريخ اسرائيل لم نسمع فيها الشعار
الذي كان يرفع سابقا دعو الجيش ينتصر
الجيش اعطي مساحه كامله ولكن كما تحدثنا
حسمت المعركه بيومها الاول عسكريا سياسيا
نفسيا وبالتالي مهما حاولت اسرائيل بال
بال 9 يوما الماضيه والايام والاسابيع
القادمه ان تعدل المشهد اعتقد تماما وفق
كل القراءات في اسرائيل ل ان الفرصه اصبحت
ضائعه واصبح جزء من من المستحيل ان ترمم
الصوره التي لحقت فيها في السابع من
اكتوبر وما لحق ذلك نعم في هذا السجال بين
السياسي والعسكري العميد الياس حنا في
سلسله من استطلاعات الراي اجراها مع
دراسات الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ونشرت
البارحه 90% من الاسرائيليين لهم ثقه
كبيره في الجيش ولكن فقط
28% لديهم مث مثل هذه الثقه في الحكومه
عندما تكون المفارقه بهذا الشكل ثقه كبيره
في الجيش وثقه مهزوزه في الحكومه وفي
المسؤولين السياسيين ما الذي يمكن ان
يحصل محمد يجب ان ان نعترف ان هناك مثل
يقول انه دائما الدول لديها جيش في
اسرائيل قد يمكن القول ان الجيش لديه دوله
حتى ان كل المسؤولين السياسيين ومنهم من
في الحكومه المصغره العسكريه وفي الحكومه
العاديه وحتى اللجنه التي الفها هليفي هي
من ضمن رؤساء الاركان السابقين والعسكريين
يعني انت اذا اردت ان تنتقل الى المستوى
السياسي الجيش هو الممر الاساسي ولكن
اليوم صوره هذا الجيش وباعتراف هليفي
وباعتراف المخابرات العسكريه وباعتراف
المساد ان هناك فشلا كبيرا وبالتالي يجب
التحقيق فيه لماذا لانه الجيش لا اول مره
لم يستطع تحقيق الاهداف العسكريه لماذا
لانه هذا الجيش دائما الجيوش التقليديه
مكونه ومدربه للبحث عن معركه فاصله وحاسم
يمكن ان يقاس النجاح فيها عندما دخل هذا
الجيش الى قطاع غزه المقاومه لم تعطه هذه
النعمه ان ان يقيس نجاحه وبالتالي ان يقدم
لل البعد السياسي هذا النجاح الاساسي
اثنين حير الجيش في انتاج ما يسمى
بالعقيده العسكريه او استراتيجيه المقاربه
لقطاع غزه وبالتالي لكل الموضوع الفلسطيني
انطلقنا من موضوع جز العشب الى موضوع
الحرب بين الحروب الى موضوع ما يسمى تعديل
العقيده العسكريه الى المومنتوم او
الاندفاع الى اخيرا وليس اخرا ومعها ليفي
الى ما يسمى العقيده العسكريه الوت او
الارتفاع والتي ترتكز على الح حروب
الهجينه يعني هو درب وانشئ مدينه مشابهه
لمدن غزه في وسط صحراء النقب للتدريب على
الحروب الهجينه او ضمن المدن كل هذه
الامور تدرب عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكنه
يسعى اليوم الى معركه فاصله يقرش فيها او
يقيس فيها النجاح هذا الامر لم يتحقق حتى
الان من هنا هذا القلق بالاضافه الى
الاصابات الى المعطوبين والذي سيكون له
تاث كبير بالاضافه الى الزلزال السياسي
الذي قد يحصل بعد وقف الحرب على غزه كما
حصل بفينو جراد واجران بالعام 73 بالاضافه
الى هذه الهزه الاجتماعيه يعني اليوم كم
من الاحتياطيين من المعطوبين سيذهب بعدها
الى القطاع الخاص للعمل نعم ايضا من بين
الخلافات بين المستوى السياسي والعسكري
وحتى بين السياسيين سيد حسام الدجني موضوع
ما يسمى باليوم التالي يعني مثل ما اوردنا
في اخبارنا العاجله في مقال ل لبيد زعيم
المعارضه في جرز لم بوست يقول لا احد
اقترح تسليم قطاع غزه الى السلطه
الفلسطينيه وان نتنياهو يتحدث عن تسليم
السلطه للرئيس الفلسطيني من باب اختلاق
عدو وهمي واعتبر ذلك
هزلياً الموضوع تسليم غزه لمن
بالضبط وهذا جزء من صوره الخلاف بين كل
مكونات الحكومه حكومه الحرب في اسرائيل
مثلا جانس هو يريد ان يسلمها للسلطه
الفلسطينيه نتنياهو واركان اليمين
والصهيونيه الدينيه في اسرائيل تريد ان
تعيد الاستيطان وتهجر الغزيين او ان يكون
هناك احتلال واعاده احتلال غزه قل خرج
بخططه لا نعلم هل هي ت بادل الادوار ام
انه يغرد خارج السرب بانه هناك اداره
المدنيه يتم تسليمها لبعض الشخصيات
القريبه من الشباب تاره يقولوا بعض
العشائر ولكن خرجت العشائر في غزه ترفض
هذا الخلاف حول اداره غزه يعكس احد
السيناريوهين او يطرح احد التساؤلين هل هو
تخبط في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه اي لا
يوجد اجابه ما هو اليوم التالي ولذلك جاء
بلينكن لكي يحصل على اجابه شافيه او يقدم
مقت حق الابم ما هو اليوم التالي لانهاء
الحرب في غزه او انه تبادل ادوار في
تقديري هو حاله تخبط حقيقي لانه عندما
يطرح نتنياهو قدوم السلطه هذا يتناقض مع
فكره الحسم التي تبنتها حكومه الحكومه
الفاشيه في اسرائيل والتي تقوم على زياده
الاستيطان وتقليل الكتله الديموغرافيه
ومحاوله التهجير واقامه المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه في غزه وحسم الضفه الغربيه
والمسجد الاقصى وغير ذلك لذلك في تقديري
انه
هذا اليوم التالي فشل في اكثر من اتجاه
فشل بان يكون هناك تهجير حتى اللحظه نقول
فشل لصمود الشعب الفلسطيني للموقف المصري
والموقف الدولي البريطاني والامريكي واغلب
الدول في العالم يرفضون التهجير بكل
اشكاله قصري او طوعي وايضا فكره اعاده
احتلال غزه المقاومه ما زالت تقول انها لم
تحسم هذه الورقه حتى تقول اسرائيل ماذا
تحدد ملامح غزه وبذلك بتنا نحن مراقبين
نشعر وكان هناك حرب نفسيه في اطار هذا
الجدل وحاله تخبط وتعكس حاله تخبط في داخل
اركان الحكومه الاسرائيليه نظرا لانها لم
تستطع حتى لحظه حسم المرحله الاولى
انتقلوا الى المرحله الثانيه ولم يستطعوا
حسم الاولى وسينتقل الى الثالثه ولم
يستطعوا حسم الثانيه والمقاومه ما زالت
على العكس تماما المشاهد التي تبثها
الجزيره والتحليل العسكري الذي يقدموها
خبرائها كلها تؤكد ان المقاومه كل يوم
افضل من القبل على عكس الخسائر في يعني
بعد اذنك والخسائر مستمره يعني بشكل
متصاعد ولو عدنا الى موضوع المعاقين سيد
عادل شديد وقد اشرت في بدايه البرنامج الى
ان الرقم قد يكون اعلى بكثير الامر قد يصل
وفق التصريحات الاسرائيليه الى احتمال
انهيار قسم اعاده التاهيل قد ينهار
بالكامل بسبب هذا الضغط ما ما صدى كل ذلك
في الاوساط الاسرائيليه كما تتا
بالتاكيد استاذ محمد لا يمكن لمراكز
التاهيل التابعه للجيش
وتحديدا في مستشفى شيبا تله شومير وهو
الاكبر لا يمكن ان يعلن عن هذا الموقف انه
المراكز على يعني شفا انهيار الا وقد وصلت
الى انهيار فعلي وقد صدر تقرير قبل اسابيع
انه هنالك الكثيرين بحاجه انتظار الدور
ولا يمكن
للاطقم طاقاتها الحاليه ان تستوعب هذا
الرقم العالي الاخذ بالازدياد يوم عن يوم
وبالمناسبه هذا الموضوع تناقض بشكل واضح
مع ما يصدر عن الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
ولولا ان لي دعوت احرونوت ولا ارتس قبل
حوالي اسابيع تطرقت هذا الموضوع وبدات
تبحث من خلال المستشفيات وال التامين
الوطني ومؤسسات اسرائيليه اخرى وكان واضح
انه هنالك فجوه واسعه وكبيره بينما يعلن
عنه من قبل الناطق العسك
وبين ما يصل مراكز التاهيل والمستشفيات
ومؤسسات التامين الوطني ومؤسسات الاحصاء
المختلفه بكل الاحوال الخطوره في هذا
الموضوع انه هذا سينعكس سلبا على معنويات
الجنود والجيش واهاليهم والمجتمع
الاسرائيلي في ظل انه في مناكفات عميقه
تضرب كل المنظومه السياسيه والامنيه في
الوقت اللي منذ 48 كان معروفا انه بكل
الحروب يتجن د الجيش الاسرائيلي والمجتمع
والاعلام والصحافه وكل مركبات المجتمع
الاسرائيلي خلف الجيش ولا مجال للحديث عن
اي موضوع اخر ها الحرب الوحيده الا
الخلافات منذ اللحظه الاولى طغت على السطح
ولا يوجد من هو قادر على منحلا بل انها
تزداد يوما عن يوم هذا جانب الجانب الثاني
انه اصبح واضح امام الجنود انه لا يوجد
هدف لهم انما هم يستخدمون اليوم كادوات وج
تنفيذي لخدمه مشروع نتنياهو الذي يريد ان
تبقى الحرب الى يوم الدين الى يوم القيامه
ومشروع بنفير وس مترش الرامي الى اعاده
الاستيطان في غزه وهذا الموضوع سينعكس
بشكل سلبي في ظل مسالتين متناقضتين كل في
بشريه اقتصاديه تزداد يوم عن يوم في
المقابل توجد جدوى و وانجازات من الممكن
ان يتم تمريرها لذلك راينا بالاسبوع
الماضي الكثير من الكتاب الذين كانوا
ملتزمين بشكل دقيق مع السرديه والروايه
الاسرائيليه قد خرجوا عنها
وبداوا يكتبون ان الروايه كاذبه وان الجيش
يكذب على على المجتمع وما على الجيش الا
ان يعيد النظر في روايته التي لم تعد تقنع
احد هذا الموضوع اعتقد انه بدا يشكل بدايه
حاله تصدع بالجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه
التي مضى على التفافها خلف الحرب لاسباب
مرتبطه بتداعيات السابع من اكتوبر ولكن
انا اعتقد انه يحد في نهايه البرنامج الى
الى موضوع الاكاذيب
لاسوق احد هذه الاكاذيب والتي تم الكشف
عنها بشكل واضح في في هذه الاجواء عميد
الياس حنا خلافات سياسيه بين السياسيين
خلافات بين السياسيين والعسكريين وتاثير
على معنويات الجيش الى درجه ان يير لبيد
زعيم المعارضه يقول هذه حكومه فاشله
وفاسده ولا تستحق تضحيات الجنود عندما
نقول لا تستحق تضحيات الجنود في وضع كهذا
ما الذي يمكن ان ان يكون مؤثر على معنويات
الجنود في في مرحله دقيقه
كهذه محمد ايضا هي العلاقه بين البعد
السياسي والاهداف الموضوعه على سبيل
المثال على سبيل المثال للحصر عندما يقول
نتنياهو سنحرر الاسرى والرهائن بالقوه
ولكن بعد ان ننهي بالقوه
سنعمله هذه المفارقه العجيبه كيف ستسمح
حماس بتسليمه الرهائن والاسرى وهي تعرف
انه يريد القضاء عليها فاذا هي هذا احدى
الاهداف التي لا يمكن تحقيقها اليوم وعلى
فكره على فكره عن عميد حنا اعاد تاكيد نفس
هذه الاهداف قبل قبل قليل ابرزها في خبر
عاجل في في مقال له اعاد واكد نفس نفس
الاهداف حرفيا
تقريبا ايه ثانيا محمد ثانيا عندما اليوم
هناك شد حبال وعد اصابع المقاومه تقول لا
لتحرير الرهائن ولا لي الا بعد وقف اطلاق
نار شامل والانسحاب من قطاع غزه هو يقول
ابدا الممكن تحقيقه عبر القوه الواقع محمد
هو الذي يعكس كل هذه المشاريع المرحله
الثالثه وحتى رؤيه جالنت التي تحدث عنها
من ثلاثه امور اولا تدمير حماس هذا الامر
ليس قابل للتحقيق اليوم اثنين ان تحكم غزه
من قبل العشائر هذا امر ايضا صعب لن يقبل
احد وثلاثه هناك لا للوجود الاسرائيليين
داخل القطاع وهذا ما يتعارض مع من طلب
ترحيل الفلسطينيين او حتى من طلب ضرب ضرب
القطاع بالقنبله النوويه واخيرا وليس اخرا
محمد ال السعي الاسرائيلي السياسي
والعسكري هو لعزل قطاع غزه عن الداخل
الاسرائيلي او فلسطين المحتله عبر ماذا
اليوم يريدون تحقيقه عبر المرحله الثالثه
تطويق الشمال فصل الوسط وبالتالي تطويق
هان يونس ومنع الصواريخ اطلاق الصواريخ من
قطاع غزه ولكن الصواريخ بحد ذاتها هي صله
الوصل لربط المسرحين مع بعضهما البعض
اليوم كما قال احد الضيوف انه اول مره في
هكذا حرب تتظاهر الخلاف لماذا لانه
المعركه تدور في المحيط المباشر لفلسطين
المحتله نعم في في اوضع ك هذه مع كل ما
ذكرناه
السيد حسام
الدجني ورقه ورقه المحتجزين لدى المقاومه
هل تزداد قيمه الان عندما يؤكد نتنياهو
على نفس الاهداف وعندما ترى المقاومه كل
هذا الارتباك داخل الساحه الاسرائيلي
يعني المقاومه وجميع المراقبين يدركون
اهميه منصب رئيس الاركان في الوعي الجمعي
الاسرائيلي
الشخصيه يعني غير الجدليه هو رئيس الاركان
ربما وزير الدفاع سيكون عليه السهام كثيره
في داخل الاوساط الاسرائيليه سواء على
المستوى الشعبي او النخبوي في تقديري ان
الخلاف بين رئيس الاركان وبين نتنياهو في
المقابل ما تقوده
المقاومه
للاسف انقطع الاتصال مع ضيفنا في غزه نسال
ضيفنا سيد عادل شديد كيف يتابع اهالي
المحتجزين كل هذه الاجواء وهم يرون ان
الامال باطلاق سراح اهاليهم ربما تزداد
تضاؤل
يعني لا شك استاذ محمد انه يوميا يزداد
قلق ليس فقط ذوي الاسرى انما يعني شرائح
واسعه من المجتمع الاسرائيلي حول مساله
لتين حول امكانيه عودتهم احياء او انه
فيما لو تم اعادتهم مستقبلا ستكون الكلفه
والفاتوره الاسرائيليه اعلى بكثير لا بل
ان هنالك احساسا يتنامى لدى الكثير من
الاسرائيليين انه لو علم نتنياهو عن مكان
وجودهم لقضى عليهم ول قصفهم وانهى هذا
الموضوع لسبب بسيط نتنياهو يرفع شعار منذ
اللحظه الاولى القضاء واجتثاث حركه حماس
وازالتها من الوجود لا يستوعب نتنياهو ان
يجد نفسه مضطرا بلحظه ما قريبا ان يكون
مقابل حماس وان يدفع الفاتوره التي
ستفرضها عليه حركه حماس بعد اذنك فقط سيد
شديد يعني بعد اذنك نعود للسيد الدجاني
الدجني عفوا حتى يكمل فكرته بعد عوده
الصوره والصوت تفضل سيد
حسام ف فعندما نقول ان ورقه المقاومه في
ظل الخلاف الواضح بين رئيس الاركان وبين
نتنياهو ومكانه اي رئيس الاركان لدى
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لتاتي المقاومه لتكمل
صوره المشهد بهذه الماده وفي ظل فشل الجيش
الاسرائيلي وفشل نتنياهو الجيش ينفذ
مخططات نتنياهو التي جاءت في مقاله اليوم
بانه سيفرج عنهم بالقوه اكثر من مشهد تم
مقتل الاسرى المحتجزين وحتى الجنود او
القوه التي اتت لانقاذهم تم استهدافها في
تقديري هذا يكمل الحلقه ام في رقبه
بنيامين نتنياهو ويكمل الطوق على نتنياهو
وبذلك يضعف من نتنياهو ويعزز من فرص
اسقاطه سياسيا لذلك هذه الورقه مهمه جدا
وقد تكون المنقذ للمقاومه ولذلك المقاومه
عندما اتخذت قرارها بان وقف شامل لاطلاق
النار في اي مبادره هو المحدد والركيزة
بالاضافه الا انها تعتبر ايضا كنز
استراتيجي فيما يتعلق بال المقاربات
السياسيه لا سيما صفقه شامله للاسر كلمه
اخيره سيد عادل شديد باختصار حول موضوع
المحتجزين وانعكاس كل ما يجري على
قضيتها يعني بموضوع المحتجزين استاذ محمد
اخطر ما قام به نتنياهو انه قام بتحريض
مجموعه من الاسرائيليين تحت عنوان ذوي
القتلى الذين قتلوا في غزه وقاموا ب ب
بصياغه وهندسه اطار ما بدعم واضح من
بنيامين نتنياهو والمقربين وخاضوا يعني
تحركات بالشارع في مواجهه
و بمعارض للتحرك المجتمعي الدرامي باتجاه
وقف اطلاق النار واعطاء الاولويه لاعاده
الاسرى نتنياهو اراد احداث شرخا عميقا ما
بين مؤيدي ذوي الاسرى واعادتهم فورا وبين
الاخرين لكي يشغل المجتمع اليهودي بذاته
في ظل حرب يجمع عليها اسرائيليا انها حربا
وجوديه هذا الموضوع اعتقد انه خلق حاله من
الانطباع لدى خصومه تنياه وهم كثر اليوم
اكثر من 76% من المجتمع اليهودي يرون
بضروره خروج نتنياهو الان من من من من من
المشهد وعدم الانتظار الى نهايه الحرب
بالتالي هذا الموضوع عمق الانطباع ان
نتنياهو اخذ اسرائيل والمنطقه باتجاه
الهاويه خدمه لمشروع شخصي ومشروع الحزبي
الضيق بالشراكه مع حلفاؤه باليمين الديني
والص الدين شكرا شكرا لك سيد عادل شديد من
الخليل شكرا لك عميد الياس حنا من بيروت
وشكرا لك حسام الدجني من غزه مثل ما
وعدتكم في موضوع الاكاذيب عوده لما نشرته
اليوم صحيفه هاردز تتذكرون ما قيل عن
اغتصاب وتحرش بالنساء تقول هاردز بانه لم
يتم العثور على ضحايا هذه الاعتداءات
الجنسيه المفترضه وان كانت هناك شهادات
فان انهم لم يعثروا عن الضحايا الذين قد
يكونون معنيين بذلك تكمله للتغطيه مع جمال
ريان